where'd you grow up were you farmers
with South Central Los Angeles my dad
sometimes cookiecutter important drugs
but mainly my mom my child was [ __ ] up
I see my mama didn't beat by different
boyfriends because she doing drugs and
drinking I'm saying me me and my twin
sister get thrown against the wall as
kid trying to protect her you know I
think the worst part of my childhood
well I think got me so angry today
mama had just one dude me and his son
uncle say his name but me and his son he
was a year older than me I was 9 so he
was team the attending Ganga chooses but
we also planned outside we got to go to
the bathroom so one by one we did in and
out the house but we [ __ ] student me
cheese he did tired of us our punching
owners that didn't work we still got to
go to the bathroom he decide
to put rubber bands on our [ __ ]
stop wasn't got to go to the bathroom no
one of my mom's boyfriend's my mom's
going to nursery school she come back
immediately run to the door I go tell my
mom I tried to her mom on climb she
welded to the bathroom I go get him the
little boy we broke on the bathroom pull
my pants down I saw my mom she started
crying I don't remember how she got that
roll Vanover see you got the road mantle
then is my friend turn this is this dude
son his biological son you can imagine
the pain we was going through this boy
cries just like me is this do don't bow
start the challenge for nothing my mom
get his walkers off the bathroom I
remember her asking him like Danny ain't
gonna get up you know get up come on
took the two doors down where my twin
sister was already at playing with the
little girls over here when I'm on
drinking buddies mom what was a bin
there she go back out I don't know how
long he was but a mirror my twin sister
run to the door because she sees my mom
but we go time we did to the doors the
Ganga poldi's surrounded my mom so
and first police grab my mom my sister
20 ran out and jumped on the police I
did they threw us get my mom down my mom
was 40 Levin and he's a big edge to me
there were giants cuz I was a [ __ ]
key and they mean like my mom's 411
party way Saturday you know they go they
tell your mom that's when I started
hating police that's when my authority
complex come in even when I went to
prison but they took my mom I'm saying
so stab him up you know it's just at 11
times
that kept they kept on being my sister
together didn't let that lady keep us
you know one of my uncle took us because
he think evening to get some money when
the money don't come he getting punched
on for asking for life sample she no
[ __ ] sugar for the cereal I says got
knocked off the dam you go go through
these one place me
know when you between you get certain
bonds every time I'll be laying down she
own girls I come on the boys are just
feeling something when I got to be it
I could trying to find our room I'll
going to walk along that girl hold till
she get up to go table but when I find
fonder my sister wrong
I see the big fat ass never I don't tell
my sister we now use old
you know I tried attacking whatever
understand and hitting the kimochi kind
he swept out on how he what he said I
remember all that where we stayed we had
two more weeks of here
thanks been in gardena there's like they
called you to solar beam that's like a
like a house where you go wait to go to
your foster floors like to challenge it
where you go to prison again next two
weeks of field
you tell you know my sister I don't know
I was scared to leave you talk about
running away
it says to have more heart I see her how
about to win who I had to go
my birthday came my twin sister you
start kicking me
she snuck over there once so she meeting
females come over don't say and they
cold you know you go baby go doing the
dumb stuff going back window you know
saying that it was all like it's good so
he decide he's my sister beat me to the
punch
she got put on the day before I got put
on be with yellow kids said come back
she got guy who scratches look like I
care who you was
we could be need to be the president and
with all his security you just went to
my sister I'm coming mad me too
13 shut up fool this is hopeful Creek
I gave man I said I knew a girl he's
dead put on back to me
are you alone
[Music]
then I started meeting I see - all my
friends did not just all came the people
of distant crying don't idea
the same group of people gonna fly
they're the same people they was going
to what I was coming to I start off with
we try to escape [ __ ]
one day we did was maybe either put me
in asleep
but then I'm having nightmares one room
two so I don't want to go to sleep so at
14 15 I'm sniffing pop my sister's still
a week don't say damn my friend got
killed and I started smoking Sharon
him if they home you say me and I'm all
sure I don't feel nothing so he's grown
man that's bigger than me ain't feeling
nothing yeah I won't that yeah and I saw
smoke concern at 14 I saw he was time
right I didn't think I had no murders no
memories I didn't want on my memory was
[ __ ] up I couldn't get past him I said
the crime I was getting thrown over the
wall I'm here against the wall for
trying to protect my mom hey mom almost
sold my little city to tell by the grace
of God she had second thought and I was
seeing I did drugs ain't good help
did you go - I went from we you know
yeah I was relaxed and I'm gonna go to
sleep so I went to the party got to be
up you know and it's sharing there's
maybe none
and then the crystal you just up so if
you up you gonna be good to tolling
shitty you won't be bored of fixing on
some then what's next you got to deal
with your thoughts I don't like my
thoughts my thoughts may be suicidal I
try to live off and I use this world
very very not lose the little friends I
do have I try to live off them when I
see them happy and yeah I can breathe I
don't
I've been smiling or whatever whatever
but when I had time with just me I don't
like me
and what are you using today
crystal we I train he peels bodies
through the hair wrong so I understand
that huh and I don't like needles and I
do [ __ ] they get fat no that's killing
people so I'm really I'm good on that
stay on the crystal like I said I don't
like me
I get called big 20 he was 26 or 27
tiebacks occurred since aunt julia pork
was always a baby mama we had two keys
dirty Marty and my daughter Colleen
maybe we got into it we broke up
whatever they might want to stay with
our mama I didn't want to come for me
being on the Coronado I was paying a
room or weekly for like 17 months they
just meaning my daughter she going to
school her hair done she was poking her
whole fatty was shocked I'm still out
here doing my thing but a third time his
daddy time that's that was keeping me
like hey I can think about do get
cracked in the park I'm in the county
you know before I go to let me call my
baby mama she's in Vegas so we I tell
her uncle I bet my mom cool I go go get
her you're gonna stay there till your
mama come back
maybe
I'm an accountant opposed to get out
August 26 2015
I'm gonna go - what are you ready for
the worker [ __ ] so I got access to the
phone
I'm extorted people within there doing
the thing is I got phone time call them
on August 24 at name speak to Iman they
speak Italian I mean Oh sheet on Street
plan no Don Street parent or friend on a
beanie okay with Tara call child call
back whatever he didn't tell me that my
daughter was in hospital we - gunshots -
her face August 24th I call it on August
24th
I don't story short I get out 26
I'll call it a 25th
where she ate oh she went to a store
able to you know I look I get out to
Paul I'm gonna come pick her up you know
go see my Pio
and you will tear a shocking new oh yes
she liked that she gonna love it
when I come I'll come home now I'm gonna
look out just uh give me you know Dale -
and I'm a bless you Oh No this is what
families do he told me that [ __ ] but
when my daughter's in hospital get out
back down here well I didn't go too
steep soon the Sun came up
I'll go see a home girl she didn't he
call he like who is this
Oh like this country oh I was just
looking for all you need to go to Long
Beach Memorial Hospital and see Tommy
she finna check out click
what the [ __ ] call back he asked you're
going straight to voicemail
Danny ringing ringing then you don't ask
the dense overall back voice mail I
finish nail my own little phone let's
see if that she watching me you been
that was wrong and I'll tell her what
she see he like my hobros I just [ __ ]
those years ago up to you you go up
there I don't know I started feeling
weird before they got door opened I was
started feeling weird cuz I'm think he
did only some drunk [ __ ] we get the
kitchen too little poof my mom would
evoke him don't you know she got me out
no care of my neck gave my daughter
named Diane expected like no I don't
know you sure she's here
oh yes she's in the wrong
so I'm waiting on them to give me my
sticker I'll go on up there and she said
I need an ID for the ponies son [ __ ]
don't know [ __ ] home I split the
pulleys and you like to output police I
want like a highway patrol officer so
let's get ready to draw their guns
because I'm finish the dial right here
you telling me my child is over here and
I ain't can't go that's out you know but
it was just missing lady and that was
kind of hard because I said I'm Rachel
but from the street politics in the
prison [ __ ] I don't like masking this
lady like lie put her job online and all
today you know I'm saying it's like
where your backpack I told you get your
tag off your backpack keep it on there
you know and say he was already up here
he's just on this thing I told you put
your tag up there come on boy okay it's
Jenica lovely
get off the elevator I see
my baby mama I see her granny I don't
see him at first
Dave mountain range stop ugly and
chronic
oh I hope not that door
it's not a baby here it is that although
man YouTube's tools everywhere
it was only a nurse in there but she
only decided beyond I don't know how you
can get to that big it was nobody
Oh Cindy holding my hand
and on our 17 minutes later she she'd
see all see
she Harvester she left
it's me being a member of the street I
understand you just what are you
supposed to do there's that being in
mind I'll go without saying
that's why I do the drugs I came here me
the last time I've been sold
from jail to
I think I like being sold how to deal
with me
yeah I all know it's like being clean I
want to be clean then I got a deal with
me and I'm cool because both my peers
were still been here if I was man enough
to get up once a month get dressed go
see a dude with a patch on pee in a
bottle part eight hour and a half on my
date my kids they live in you I was so
caught up in my [ __ ] my addictions
goddess's addiction gangbanging this
addiction shooting dies with the homies
addiction that robbery isn't the dope -
doesn't that she be calling you now
I don't mind being in the job little
sweet I I get off working might I be off
and I'll be right in the city home he
says don't want sitting like on ceiling
so yes you told me about your
fourteen-year-old daughter oh they're
doing this time her mama didn't want to
I want to kill her uncle she didn't want
to tell me where he was at so I'm
tripping on our family members cocktail
in her house I'm shooting that
[ __ ] up I've got my home quilt
jumping or jumping family members could
you tell you turning in turn him in then
I would have stopped but she didn't so
my daughter I always like she got on the
bus
my baby mama cousin her daughter 12
gusty Georgia she called me when she
were going to bus are you on the bus too
weird
I'm going to Georgia
star
maybe
year before she passed and my grandbaby
I see me up on Facebook get to talking
should I date he the reason why I had to
leave good I was watching Mike I just
lost my sister I guess y'all forgot
about that and I watched my daddy trying
to kill my family the other side of my
family
I wasn't mad I was proud she she was -
she was 20 to have her baby she had a
job she was doing her we don't her [ __ ]
man
one day she's gone she come back from
work go get my grandbaby from daycare
drunk masking I guess was texting and
cried you to her car that's how I lost
down
I saw snowing down on markers right back
I'm a grimy this is heaven didn't
calculate that she died in Augusta
Georgia goes to jury
just about to do it
at work two sisters-in-law guys some
going on with my brain since I to go do
some some surgery which they say seven
isn't changed hours on my head you get
to [ __ ] with Allah Almighty is
playing it better basically
one day I'm wiggler - especially he told
my auntie putting the name in turns this
imagine you wake up blank so all that to
say why I'm stopped in hi doing what I'm
doing
ain't got no lighting in the Martin
okay I'm gonna watch sometimes I don't
care about getting beat up
I'm ugly already going to give me a
black guy my show my black guy turning
him on to a circle which is a dot give
us yeah
Thank You smush Parker
you